some breaking news uh
the queen
has decided it's been announced this
morning that with regret she will not be
attending the remembrance uh sunday uh
ceremonies this morning that is breaking
news that is just coming and we're now
going to talk to rhiannon mills our
royal correspondent who i think is in
whitehall right now
right of course there was a huge amount
of anticipation about whether or not her
majesty would be here for a remembrance
sunday on thursday we were told that she
would be attending however in the last
few moments we have had a statement from
buckingham palace confirming that
unfortunately her majesty will not
be attending the cenotaph today now i
can read you the statement that they've
sent through
which says the queen having sprained her
back has decided this morning with great
regret that she'll not be able to attend
today's remembrance sunday service at
the cenotaph her majesty is disappointed
that she'll miss the service so i think
one thing to point out there is they're
saying that she has sprained her back
also i understand that the back's brain
is unrelated to the recent doctor's
advice that we know that she's had
over the last couple of weeks to rest
it is obviously really unfortunate
timing but this back sprain has happened
very recently and we're also told that
nobody regrets the fact that the queen
can't be here
more than the queen herself she is
deeply disappointed not least because
she regards today as one of the most
significant engagements
of the year and of course that is
because she is a member of that wartime
generation during the second world war
she saw her father rallying
the nation as king and also of course
her husband prince philip who died
earlier this year
served during the second world war uh as
well um just to
stress though we are hearing that
because of a back sprain the queen will
not be able to attend
the events here today however other
members of her family will still be here
in force in attendance of course in
recent years the queen has handed over
that responsibility
of placing a wreath at the base of the
cenotaph on behalf of the nation she's
handed that responsibility to her son
and heir the prince of wales he will
again
carry out that duty but just to stress
we will not see the queen here at the
center half today